back here at the white house the
likelihood of a summit between President
Trump and Kim Jong Hwan seems to be
growing by the day a top North Korean
official has been dispatched to New York
he will meet meet with America's top
diplomat Wednesday all of this comes
less than a week after President Trump
canceled the planned
Singapore summit chief White House
correspondent and John Roberts is here
on the North Lawn with me too not Jim
jump right good evening to you the White
House isn't yet ready to declare the
summit back on and even if it is back on
it may be impossible to hold it on June
the 12th may have to be slid back a
couple of days but the planning is
proceeding full steam ahead President
Trump today maintained his upbeat
assessment of a summit with Kim jong-un
tweeting this morning that one of the
highest ranking officials in North Korea
was headed to the US kim gyeong-cheol
the vice chairman of north korea heading
now to new york the president tweeted
solid response to my letter thank you
kim yeongcheol was the head of north
korea's cyber spying agency and was
sanctioned by the Obama administration
in 2015 for allegedly orchestrating the
hack attack on Sony Pictures he was also
at Kim jong-un side during the meeting
with South Korean president moon jae-in
the turnaround with North Korea happened
after President Trump shocked the world
sending Kim a letter last Thursday
calling off the summit this president in
that letter last week I thought really
got some kinetic energy going folks all
of a sudden said wow this may actually
not happen and if we want it to happen
then we're going to start moving it ever
since then practically North Korea South
Korea and the United States have been
making very positive moves
the administration has two teams in the
region one led by deputy chief of staff
Jo Hagan is in Singapore to work out the
logistics of a possible summit another
team is at the DMZ nailing down some of
the diplomatic issues and Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo will meet in New York
tomorrow with kim yeongcheol we are
still finalizing exactly what these
meetings will look like but the
secretary will be heading up to New York
tomorrow and I believe returning
sometime on Thursday I think it's pretty
impressive thinking about where we were
one year ago where we were even six
months ago for that matter and now we
have three simultaneous meetings taking
place on this
to talk about the denuclearization of
the Korean Peninsula and president Trump
will have one last meeting with Japanese
Prime Minister Shinzo Abe a ahead of
June 12th
obby will visit the White House next
Thursday to talk strategy Japan wants to
make sure its interests are represented
the threat from North Korea's
intermediate-range ballistic missiles
and Japanese citizens kidnapped by North
Korea at their mar-a-lago summit an
April President Trump promised he would
raise it we're going to do everything
possible to have them brought back and
bring them back to Japan I gave you that
promise
president Trump is sought Chinese
President Xi Jinping's help in bringing
North Korea to the table but today a
possible complicating factor the White
House announcing it will soon impose a
25% tariff on 50 billion dollars in
Chinese imports and implement investment
restrictions and enhanced export
controls on us technology China
responded tersely to what it saw as a
negotiating tactic in broader trade
talks in a statement the Ministry of
Commerce saying we are surprised by the
strategic statement released by the
White House but at the same time it is
somewhat expected and President Trump
got some blowback over a tweet he set
out on Memorial Day when he posted happy
Memorial Day those who died for our
great country would be very happy and
proud at how well our country is doing
today best economy in decades lowest
unemployment numbers for blacks and
Hispanics ever and women in 18 years
rebuilding our military and so much more
nice that prompted a sober response from
the former chairman of the Joint Chiefs
of Staff General Martin Dempsey tweeting
this day of all days of the year should
not be about any one of us no matter how
prestigious or powerful no matter how
successful we perceive ourselves to be
the president's tone was far different
when he gave the yearly address at the
Arlington National Cemetery honoring
those who gave their lives in defense of
this country the first daughter Ivanka
Trump seemed to get it just a bad pitch
perfect when she treated it tweeted out
quote as we remember our fallen
servicemen and women our hearts are
filled with gratitude for their
sacrifice and
of their courage breath another aspect
of Ivanka Trump raising some eyebrows
about the business sighs some people are
casting a skeptical eye at the fact that
she recently received from China seven
new trademarks and then shortly after
that the president cut a deal with Xi
Jinping to resurrect the Chinese telecom
giant ZTE Abigail Klem who runs the
Ivanka Trump brand for the first
daughter said that this business as
usual they were simply trying to protect
the trademarks in an era when there are
so many trademark violations the White
House pointing out that while the
President did cut a deal with Xi Jinping
to save ZTE he also this morning said
that he was set to impose a 25% tariff
on 50 billion dollars worth of Chinese
goods thought of moving parts John as
always thank you